nach verstößen gegen korona auflagen in
berlin kontroverse debatte über die
grenzen des versammlungsrechts auf
demonstration
urlaub in der türkei
die bundesregierung hebt die
reisewarnung für einige küstenregionen
auf ohne alkohol und gästefans im
stadion
die deutsche fußball liga legt
vorschläge für eine schrittweise
rückkehr der zuschauer vor
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend bekommt man
den heute -nachrichten mit dabei für den
sport norbert lehmann frische bilder von
mir die großdemonstrationen gegen die
cola beschränkungen in berlin wirkt nach
weil dabei bewusst gegen auflagen
verstoßen wurde
mas getragen und abstand wahren wird nun
über konsequenzen diskutiert wie setzt
man die hygieneregeln durch sollten
demonstrationen während der pandemie
verboten werden oder muss man das
versammlungsrecht auch dann schützen
wenn andere dadurch gefährdet werden
andreas huppert ist diesen fragen
nachgegangen
zu viele zu wenig abstand kein mund
nasenschutz berlin vergangenen samstag
tausende ignorieren bewusst alle hygiene
auflagen die teilnehmer der demo gegen
die korona maßnahmen fühlen sich
gegängelt eingeschränkt und bevor man
stimmen werden laut solche demos
generell zu verbieten die
bundesjustizministerin will das
ausdrücklich nicht
ich finde es ganz wichtig dass wieder
demonstrationen stattfinden können und
menschen dort ihre meinung auch zur
aktuellen corona politik der
bundesregierung frei und öffentlich
äußern können das hohe gut des
versammlungsrechts auf der einen die
behördliche auflagen zum corona schutz
auf der anderen seite die politik muss
abwägen
ein teil der leute hat ja wirklich
berechtigte anliegen die ich verstehe
aber ein teil ist auch recht der sumpf
der das missbraucht für politische
zwecke hygieneregeln hin oder her die
afg lobt die demonstranten es sei eben
schwierig bei so vielen menschen die
abstandsregel einzuhalten also erstmal
lobenswerten das begrüßen wir natürlich
als afd dass man hier seine grundrechte
auch demonstrativ zum ausdruck bringt
für die grünen ist klar wer die
allgemeinheit gefährdet verwirkt dadurch
sein recht auf versammlungsfreiheit
diese auflagen diadem dem schutz der
allgemeinheit dienen die müssen
durchgesetzt haben und zwar bei der
anreise bei der abreise bei der
demonstration demonstrationsrecht contra
infektionsschutz in den kommenden wochen
sind bundesweit neue demos gegen die
staatlichen chor ohne auflagen
platz und bei mir ist im studio ist
jetzt christian decker aus unserer
redaktion recht und justiz christian der
verstoß gegen die korona auflagen am
samstag war ja quasi programm gilt das
versammlungsrecht denn auch dann wenn
dadurch andere gefährdet werden
die versammlungsfreiheit ist ein hohes
gut ein sehr wichtiges grundrecht in der
demokratie in das nicht so leicht
eingegriffen werden kann
das gilt übrigens auch für meinungen die
wissenschaftlich längst widerlegt sind
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat in den
vergangenen monaten mehrmals klar
gestellt dass ja auch in der korona zeit
für versammlungen demonstrationen nicht
einfach pauschal verboten werden dürfen
es mag extremfälle geben ausnahmefälle
wenn zb der veranstalter von vornherein
sagt wir werden gegen die auflagen
verstoßen alle teilnehmenden werden
keinen mundschutz tragen das sind aber
ausnahmefälle
nun fordern ja schon einige politiker
schärfere auflagen für solche
demonstration wäre das überhaupt möglich
ja das dürfte eher schwierig werden denn
jede einzelne auflage muss
verhältnismäßig sein
das bedeutet die behörde muss immer das
mildeste mittel wählen um den
gesundheitsschutz der bevölkerung zu
erreichen
konkretes beispiel wenn eine
demonstration die auflage hat den
mindestabstand einzuhalten und einem und
nasen bedeckung alles tragen müssen dann
ist das mit sicherheit ein milderes
mittel als wenn an der demonstration
maximal 20 personen teilnehmen dürfen
im endeffekt ist es also immer eine
abwägung zwischen einerseits der
versammlungsfreiheit und auf der anderen
seite der gesundheitsschutz von uns
allen ja interessant vielen dank des mdk
danke das auswärtige amt hat die
reisewarnungen für teile der türkei
aufgehoben
das gilt für die bei touristen beliebten
provinzen antalya izmir aydin und muller
wegen des niedrigen corona
infektionsgeschehen es dort seien reisen
unbedenklich die türkei hatte noch
anfang juli eine delegation nach berlin
geschickt um in politischen gesprächen
eine aufhebung der reisewarnung zu
erreichen
zuletzt waren deshalb die beziehungen
zwischen beiden ländern angespannt
nachfrage dort bei conergy was
verspricht sich die bundesregierung von
dieser entscheidung
also vor allem mehr sicherheit das
würden wir hier aus regierungskreisen
das klingt zwar erstmal paradox wenn mit
der freigabe beliebte urlaubsregionen
natürlich auch mehr reisebewegungen zu
erwarten sind aber die türkei hat sich
im gegenzug dazu verpflichtet alle
ausreichenden also alle reiserückkehrer
zu überprüfen schärfer zu kontrollieren
und niemanden ausreisen zu lassen denn
nicht einen maximal 48 stunden alten
negativen krohn attest vorweisen kann
das heißt also wer keinen corona test
hat bei der ausreise oder wer infiziert
ist darf das land erst einmal nicht
verlassen
und das führt so die ansicht der
bundesregierung natürlich zu mehr
sicherheit und nimmt auch ein wenig last
von deutschlands schultern
bei dem testen von reiserückkehrern
hinzu kommt ein zusätzliches plus man
geht mit dieser maßnahme einen schritt
auf die türkei zu die immer noch ein
wichtiger verbündeter für die
bundesregierung ist zum beispiel bei der
flüchtlingspolitik und das ist aus sicht
der bundesregierung sicher eine win win
situation
vielen dank für ihre einschätzung konnte
die afd kommt nicht zur ruhe
schauplatz des innerparteilichen
machtkampf war heute die
landtagsfraktion in brandenburg es ging
um die frage ob der rechtsextremist
andreas kalbitz fraktionschef bleiben
soll obwohl das bundesschiedsgericht der
afg seinen rausschmiss aus der partei
bestätigt hatte das ergebnis kalbitz
lässt den fraktionsvorsitz bis auf
weiteres ruhen
manche klingbeil und jan meyer berichten
sondersitzung der afg heute im
brandenburger landtag nach vier stunden
gab es dann das für viele überraschende
ergebnis auf meinen vorschlag den die
fraktion einstimmig beschlossen oder
zudem einem antrag zugestimmt den
fraktionsvorsitz ruhen zu lassen bis zum
zeitpunkt der einen der entscheidung
über das einstweilige
rechtsschutzverfahren beim landgericht
berlin
afg chef jörg meyer begrüßte die
entscheidung
die brandenburger fraktion hat
vernünftig entschieden indem sie gesagt
hat er kann jetzt nicht unter den
gegebenen umständen das
landesvorsitzender sein
im letzten september holte die
brandenburger afd mit rechtsaußen
andreas kalbitz 23 prozent der stimmen
keine zehn monate später stuft der
verfassungsschutz den gesamten
landesverband als rechtsextrem 1
es folgt der parteiausschluss von
kalbitz durch den bundesvorstand
initiiert von jörg leuten doch der
einfluss des volkes nationalistischen
flügels bleibt stark wenn leuten auf dem
parteitag wann immer auf leicht im
september die mehrheit bekommt wird die
der flügel die leute um hecke und
kallwitz einen teufel tun aus der partei
heraus zu gehen
das heißt der machtkampf vertieft sich
auch in den nächsten monaten eine
vermittlung wie früher durch deutschland
ist nicht sichtbar nach außen hin
zumindest heute geschlossenheit in der
brandenburger fdp fraktion doch der
machtkampf in der bundes partei geht
weiter die jusos brauchen einen neuen
vorsitzenden kevin kühnert 31 will im
november vorzeitig abtreten und für den
nächsten bundestag kandidieren kunert
hat sich immer wieder gegen die
regierungsbeteiligung an der seite der
union gewarnt
der stellvertretende parteivorsitzende
gilt als eine führende stimme der linken
in der spd
kommen wir zu den aktuellen zahlen der
korona pandemie in deutschland da zeigt
sich weiterhin eine steigende tendenz
im durchschnitt der letzten sieben tage
haben sich täglich 710 menschen mit dem
virus infiziert gestern waren es noch
650 besonders schwierig ist die
situation in mamming in niederbayern
erst gab es dort ein crooner ausbruch
mit mehr als 200 infizierten in einem
gemüsehof dann hat es eine
konservenfabrik ganz in der nähe
erwischt dort sind inzwischen insgesamt
166 beschäftigte positiv getestet worden
patricia schäfer berichtet
die neuen infektionen gehen auf diese
konservenfabrik zurück bereits am
wochenende war der betrieb im
niederbayerischen mamming geschlossen
und eine strenge quarantäne verhängt
wurden bei einem weiteren test wurden
nun 123 neue fälle festgestellt
es war ehrlich gesagt zu erwarten das
war beim ersten betrieb genau so dass
die zahl der infizierten steigt weil sie
eben auf engem raum zusammen wohnen dass
sie so stark ansteigt hat uns ehrlich
gesagt auch überrascht
die zahl der infizierten verdreifachte
sich seit dem wochenende obwohl die
meisten mitarbeiter der konservenfabrik
in festen gebäuden untergebracht sind
dort hat jeder bewohner ein einzelzimmer
mit eigenem bad
trotz allem haben wir die erste zahl der
positiven ab verlegt um sind gerade in
verhandlungen die wir jetzt mit der
höheren zahl umgehen dass wir das auch
räumlich trennen und die wohnsituation
trotz der deutlich besseren
verhältnissen noch weiter entfernen
können
der nahegelegenen gemüsehof in mamming
ist weiträumig abgesperrt inzwischen
kontrolliert die polizei die einhaltung
der quarantäne
insgesamt standen rund 750 mitarbeiter
und kontaktpersonen beider betriebe
unter quarantäne
alle saison arbeiter aus osteuropa die
ersten von ihnen durften die quarantäne
bereits wieder verlassen
alle 5000 bisher durchgeführten tests
unter den übrigen bewohnern des
landkreises dingolfing-landau waren
durchweg negativ dennoch heißt der neue
ausbruch für den 3000 einwohner ort
mamming weiter erhöhte vorsicht damit
das virus nicht überspringt auf die
dorfbewohner die libanesische hauptstadt
beirut ist von mehreren explosionen
erschüttert worden
sie ereigneten sich in der nähe des
hafens nach der stärksten detonation gab
es eine gigantische druckwelle dichter
rauch steht über der stadt
die zahl der opfer ist noch völlig
unklar die behörden rechnen mit sehr
vielen verletzten und toten
uli gack anschlag oder unfall können sie
schon irgendetwas zum hintergrund sagen
ja was kann man in dieser region
ausschließen einen schlag ist momentan
eher unwahrscheinlich aber man kann es
eben nicht
ausschließen die hafen direktion hat
gerade gesagt dass in dieser region sehr
viele chemikalien gelagert waren es war
auch davon die rede dass er viele
sprengstoffe feuerwerk vielleicht sogar
auch ein treibstofflager dort war das
würde die riesige explosion erklären wir
hören aber auch dass in dieser in diesem
gebiet ein großes waffenlager der
radikalislamischen hisbollah war die
dort eben möglicherweise in die luft
geflogen ist sind es gibt sehr viele
spekulationen die momentan ins kraut
schießen in dieser region es heißt auch
wahrscheinlich unglaubwürdigen aber
immerhin dass israel dahinter stecken
könnte
das wird in dieser region immer
behaupten dass unvorhergesehenes
passiert momentan ist die situation
unklar es hat wohl drei enorme explosion
gegeben
die druckwelle hatten in der ganzen
stadt gespürt was letztendlich die
ursache war
wir wissen es zur stunde noch nicht
vielen dank für diesen ersten
informationen vielen dank uli gack
argentinien befindet sich seit vielen
jahren immer wieder in schweren
wirtschaftskrisen die aktuelle
schieflage ist durch corona noch mal
verschärft worden es drohte die neunte
staatspleite weil das land seine
schulden nicht mehr begleichen konnte
nun zeichnet sich eine lösung ab
zumindest kurzfristig die privaten
gläubiger haben eine umschuldung
zugestimmt
das dürfte aber nichts an der situation
der menschen ändern die von der
wirtschaftskrise gebeutelt sind wie
christoph rath berichtet wenn es abend
wird in la bocca in buenos aires füllen
sich die gassen hunderte stehen an vor
der casa san der armenküche des viertels
drinnen kochen sandra und zahlreiche
freiwillige jeden tag
man muss mit liebe kochen man sollte
menschen in not nicht irgendwas zu essen
geben etwa 500 familien sind inzwischen
angewiesen auf die hilfe totti as
polenta und fleisch nahrhaft muss es
sein die meisten hier gehören zur
mittelschicht doch die anhaltende
wirtschaftskrise und jetzt auch noch
corona haben sie an den rand ihrer
existenz gebracht
es ist mir am anfang unangenehm gewesen
wenn du etwas hast dann hilfst du
anderen auch wenn es wenig ist und
plötzlich bist du selbst in der
situation bedürftig zu sein
das ist nicht einfach einfach ist es
schon lange nicht mehr in argentinien 50
prozent inflation rekordschulden und
jetzt so gerade eben an der neunten
staats pleite vorbeigeschrammt
in letzter minute haben sich argentinien
und die internationalen gläubiger auf
eine umschuldung geeinigt an den
grundlegenden problemen aber ändert das
nichts befürchten experten
ich glaube dass es ohne reformen kein
vertrauen in argentinien gibt eine
steuerreform eine staatsreform einer
rentenreform und eine arbeits reform das
ist das mindeste über jahrzehnte haben
populistische regierungen auf kosten der
staatskasse ihre klientel bedient
mangelnde rechtssicherheit hat viel
vertrauen zerstört und der abstieg nach
am selbstvertrauen des einst stolzen
landes es dürfte jahre dauern bis
argentinien aus der krise heraus kommt
nun zu einem früheren könig der nicht
nur seinen palast den rücken kehrt
sondern im ganzen land fuhren carlos
verlässt spanien und hinterlässt ein
königshaus dessen ansehen leidet
dabei war er lange zeit beliebt half er
doch spanien aus der franco diktatur in
die demokratie
dann kamen die schlagzeilen über affären
und seine luxus reise in der
wirtschaftskrise wie hier mit elefanten
jagd vor allem aber ist da der
korruptionsskandal um juan carlos der
die spanische krone sehr belastet thomas
walde juan carlos nennt ist exil seine
landsleute vor dem palast in madrid
nennen ist anders er hätte hier bleiben
müssen um dem spanischen volk rede und
antwort zu stehen es ist eine art flucht
er kann gehen nachdem er zurückgegeben
hat was er geklaut hat wenn er das geld
hier lässt keine abhauen montanus
schreibt sohn könig philipp er wolle ihn
nicht belasten mit öffentlichen
konsequenzen bestimmter geschehnisse der
vergangenheit gemeint sind
ermittlungsverfahren
es geht um mutmaßliche schmiergelder
beim bau einer bahnstrecke
saudi arabien juan carlos soll laut
berichten bis zu 100 millionen dollar
erhalten haben
aus spanischer perspektive glaube ich
ist es nicht mehr tragbar
hier das ganze in sande verlaufen zu
lassen ein verfahren wird weiterhin
stattfinden
juan carlos werde schreibt sein anwalt
ermittlern zur verfügung stehen der
regierungschef versucht derweil die
wogen zu glätten wird sollen der
entscheidung des königshauses absoluten
respekt sich zu distanzieren von
mutmaßlichen fällen die gegenstand von
ermittlungen sind investigativ ihren
respekt genauso an carlos wegen seiner
rolle beim übergang spaniens von der
diktatur zur demokratie eine reihe von
skandalen darunter eine luxus safari
beschädigte seinen ruf könig philipp ii
distanzierte sich er verzichtete auf
persönliches erbe das so wörtlich nicht
im einklang mit der legalität stehen
könnte tja und nun zu dir norbert und
zum konzept der deutschen fußball-liga
dass eine rückkehr der fans in die
stadion ermöglichen soll
und da geht es um vier zentrale punkte
vorübergehend keine stehplätze keine
gästefans kein alkohol und es soll
personalisierte tickets für alle
stadionbesuchern geben die fan
organisation wenig begeistert das letzte
wort haben die gesundheitsbehörden
lange hat sie beraten die
mitgliederversammlung der dfl und kam
dann zu einem eindeutigen ergebnis es
gab zu allen vier präsidiums beschlossen
dann auch entsprechenden mehrheiten und
ist ein gutes fundament dafür dass wir
dann jetzt die nächsten schritte machen
könnte das heißt dass jede einzelne vor
allem mit den jeweiligen lokalen
behörden dann über eine teilöffnung
diskutieren muss also die entscheidung
liegt letztlich bei der politik und den
regionalen ämter die dfl präsentiert
sich entsprechend zurückhaltend
priorität in deutschland haben derzeit
nicht volle stadien
priorität hat nach wie vor die
gesundheitliche situation aus
wissenschaftlicher sicht gibt es auch
zweifel am konzept
man will das durch gutachten lösen
vonseiten der dfl wenn die gesundheit
aber wie kann man ein gutachten stein
wenn es gar keine wissenschaftlichen
daten dazu gibt das virus ist einfach
noch zu unerfahren
doch vielleicht kommen gar nicht so
viele zuschauer ich glaube dass die
organisierten fans tatsächlich aber
darauf verzichten werden ins stadion zu
gehen
da gilt das motto alle oder keiner aber
die dfl leitlinien stehen sowieso
nächsten montag auf dem prüfstand dann
treffen sich die gesundheitsminister der
länder fußball vor kleinem publikum das
gab es heute schon in mönchengladbach
beim ersten mannschaftstraining der
borussia 300 zuschauer waren zugelassen
mit den fans im rücken rüstet sich
gladbach für bundesliga dfb pokal und
champions league
nur wer sich vorher online registriert
hat darf dabei sein bei dem spektakel
dennoch einige borussen fans in
skeptisch was den stadionbesuch betrifft
ich würde auch jetzt definitiv nicht die
dinger vollmachen wieder da muss man
schon gucken dass man ja den
vertrauensvorschuss den fußballer
gekriegt hat jetzt nicht mit
mit zu schnell und zu viel und wieder
aufs spiel setzt trainer marco rose
setzt auch seinen leistungsträger
matthias ginter der den offerten aus dem
ausland widerstanden hat und baut auf
die unterstützung der fans die hoffnung
ist sehr groß ich glaube wir müssen im
moment alle alle kompromisse machen und
wissen dass es nicht so einfach ist wir
werden kein volles stadion haben in
nächster zeit doch diese pappkameraden
im borussia park sind bald geschichte
20.000 echt kameraden würden natürlich
fühle
ja stimmt und wir haben noch eine art
robinson crusoe geschichte für sie von
drei gestrandeten seglern die männer
waren im westpazifik mit ihrem boot vom
kurs abgekommen und ohne treibstoff an
den strand einer winzigen insel
getrieben worden
ohne kontakt zur außenwelt malten sie in
ihrer not ein riesiges sos in den sand
nach drei tagen entdeckte dass ein
australisches marine flugzeug die
gestrandeten wurden mit wasser und essen
versorgt und per schiff gerettet
gegen jedenfalls erheblich schneller als
bei robinson crusoe zum wetter weiter
gelten unwetterwarnungen wegen
dauerregens für den süden bayerns und
eine neue hitzewelle rollt heran wie
heißt es wann wo wird das erfahren sie
gleich von terry so viel von uns danke
für ihr interesse marietta slomka bringt
sie später im heute journal auf den
neuesten stand und wir sind morgen abend
wieder für sie da punkt ziehen bis dahin
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter die nächste
hitzewelle rollt heran und die kommt von
spanien über frankreich nach deutschland
und hier eingezeichneten in orange tönen
mindestens die 30 grad flächen und die
sind sogar bis nach skandinavien
ausgedehnt dort gibt es ein
umfangreiches hoch in den nächsten tagen
und das hält sich dann bis in die
nächste woche
schauen wir in die nacht im süden lässt
der regen endlich nach sonst ist es
wiederum viel zu trocken und an der
nordsee wird es stürmisch aus südwest
bei temperaturen einstellige werte 9 bis
6 grad im süden 14 grad an der nordsee
lüften sie noch mal kräftig durch bevor
die nächste hitzewelle heranrollt morgen
viel sonnenschein im westen entlang des
rheins bis zum main sonst überwiegend
harmlose bewölkung bei temperaturen bis
31 grad am niederrhein
sonst legen wir meist unter der 30 grad
marke mit 19 grad an den alpen wird es
am kühlsten seien die nächsten tage am
donnerstag bis 33 grad heiß sehr viel
sonnenschein am freitag den sich die
hitze auch nach osten aus und am samstag
auch in den norden und dann bis zu 37
grad
ein schöner habt